Social media has really made everything annoying,
hasn't it?
I think great too though.
Both do Twitter.
It's like,
look,
we're saying when someone says something dumb,
like Trump will say something dumped sometimes and I'll just go there for the
memes and I'll just read his post and it'll get me going in the more I'll get
like 15 minutes of ha ha's.
Probably miss the story yesterday.
Have you heard any of the 21 savage news?
Oh,
he got deported,
right?
Because everyone found out yesterday that he's apparently from the UK.
And so like the story,
there's two stories that as part of the story,
but memes of him being from the UK and a British rapper that's Rosie from
Atlanta really took over to the fact like Demi Lavato tweeted it and she got
shit on and she's deleted her Twitter now because of the response to that.
Did you know who this guy was before?
No,
but I'm 51 years old.
Yeah.
Old Man.
Number one.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
Number one write record.
And now like in the country,
really?
Jamie's on black Twitter cheese,
but you're on black Twitter.
Sure,
sure.
It could be too.
I,
yeah,
my fall,
a lot of them and I don't know any of these like tech nines and Sushi fours
fucked that.
Takeshi.
Six.
Nine.
He's fucked.
Maybe.
What do you mean may blow the sand?
He's,
he's talking.
We might get a lot of,
he's still fucked.
He's fun.
He's going to jail for a long time with a tattoo of six,
nine on his face.
He's going to jail.
He's going to have real problems.
That ain't good there.
The man did you read the list of charges?
There's murder involved.
Murder.
Conspiracy.
Oh,
of him supposedly calling a hit on someone.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my God.
Oh,
he's fucked man.
Even if he cooperates,
if they put a hit on someone because he said it.
Jesus,
he'll,
he won't get like the death penalty,
but now he wasn't being like life in prison.
You know someone's fleshlight.
Yeah.
Heck yeah.
It's a real problem.
Soldier boys in jail too,
isn't he?
Is for what got arrested.
I didn't.
Hey,
did what?
He beat up his girl and his girl beat him up.
No,
no,
that was a little bow.
Wow.
He was the son of a bitch.
You just shamed Soulja boy for no reason.
With your Shitty Pot,
adult memory weight as you son of a bitch.
Jamie's right.
I know.
It was a little bow.
Wow.
No,
there was something else.
Oh,
hold on.
Yup.
Nope.
He's accused of kidnapping a woman apparently.
I'm sorry.
So you got the stories conflated,
kidnapped,
because even worse,
he tied a girl to a,
uh,
a chair using an extension cord and kept her for six or seven hours and his
garage hit.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Oh,
he's going to jail forever.
Prom.
What do you do that for?
That someone's daughter wouldn't do that for a jealousy.
I think it said Ed.
This is apparently according to celebrity news outlet.
The woman whose name I will not say apparently was backing out of a driveway in
her car,
hit soldiers la home when she hit the curb at his house,
when she hit the curb.
From that point on,
his assistant reportedly became upset and started fighting with her from there.
Soldier allegedly stepped outside and tried to break up the fight.
The woman says that he began punching and kicking her when she was on ground and
then tied her up for six hours.
God,
Soulja boy.
Well,
at least Nintendo one was cooler heads will prevail,
but that sounds like that sounds like a fucking disaster.
Jesus Christ.
You never hear about the spin doctors causing any problems,
right,
guys?
She hit a curb.
This all started.
She heard it.
She hit a curb with his car or something.
She's curved.
One was wheels on enough information on there.
I don't know.
Yeah.
She probably curbed one of his wheels probably has a nice car and she didn't
know what the fuck she was doing.
I got a job.
What?
A Dick tied her up and beat her up.
That's Jesus' grace,
allegedly,
allegedly.
Right,
right,
right.
You got to always say that.